même le douanier est accueillant ciao
cela n'a l'air de rien mais il y a à
peine 20 ans il était impossible pour
des touristes indépendants comme eux de
franchir cette frontière de cette
manière l'albanie est l une des
dictatures communistes les plus fermés
du monde
c'était bien un jour on ira voir
pourquoi pendant autant de temps ils ont
réussi à maintenir ce régime fermé mais
comme vous voyez fermer les l'instant
frappe à la porte ont réussi à rentrer
c'est quand même bien d'être maintenant
en albanie ce qui les attire
c'est l'histoire singulière de ce pays
méconnu une histoire qui a laissé son
empreinte dans le paysage 800000 bunker
comme celui ci sont disséminés dans tout
le pays
symbole de la paranoïa du dictateur
enver hodja au pouvoir de 1946 à 1985 il
craignait une invasion étrangère
premiers clichés du pays pour la petite
troupe n'est pas à part on y rentre sur
le côté là c'était prévu pour deux
personnes
eh bien c'était la corée du nord ici on
aime voir ce genre de choses parce que
ça fait comme on dit patrimoine mais je
pense sincèrement que pour eux s'ils
pouvaient les casser détruire je pense
que ça disparaît très dramatique quand
même le monde a changé dans le bon sens
a quand même
claude et claudine les camping caristes
poursuivre leur voyage
l'état des routes étaient leurs grandes
inquiétudes mais ils sont agréablement
surpris
pour l'instant il s'agit de ne pas
s'égarer dans la voix n'est demandé
vous avez le monde pardon le camping
albania album we are bouche de l'autre
côté à embaucher un peu de langage des
signes
quelques mots d'italien et de français
les hommes finissent par se comprendre
quant au kilomètre et des cours non la
bien mauvaise grâce féminine
les touristes vont passer la nuit sur un
terrain de camping un camping ouvert en
2009 par un couple de hollandais
c'était le premier du pays bonjour
bienvenue en albanie par les néerlandais
d'accord anglais bienvenus et pour
l'emplacement vous pouvez vous installer
merci je vous en prie
[Musique]
pour 10 euros par jour les camping
caristes ont l'embarras du choix parfait
très bien tu as vu un peu l'atlas qui ne
peut y avoir là bas le père braud hélène
et son mari dick se sont installés ici
il y a huit ans avec leurs trois enfants
l'an dernier ils ont accueilli sept
mille campeurs
ça ne s'est pas fait tout seul il ya
huit ans les routes n'étaient même pas
boudronnée il n'y avait que deux heures
d'électricité par jour et pour laver les
enfants ça se passait à l'ancienne on
faisait chauffer l'eau ici qu'on a vu
l'albanie se transformer notre première
visite c'était il ya 18 ans aujourd'hui
le pays est en plein essor
[Musique]
leur amour du pays dick et hélène aime
le faire partager à leurs clients
et
ils ont proposé aux quatre français de
rencontrer un de leurs amis
un agriculteur qui habite à quelques
kilomètres de chez eux
une rencontre avec une famille albanaise
c'est exactement le type de visite que
les français espéraient
oui
mais pas évident
bonjour ya qu à 62 ans
il produit du raki une sorte de vie
locale c'est le fournisseur officiel du
camping il tient à nous recevoir chez
lui c'est important pour les albanais on
y va yak ouvre souvent la porte de sa
maison aux touristes ou la malaisie il
lui dit d'aller nous asseoir il invite
ici avec son fils sa belle fille et son
épouse il est heureux de partager son
histoire et celle de son pays avec des
étrangers c'est du bon acquis avant ici
c'était la dictature et c'est est rude
quand les frontières se sont ouvertes
c'était incroyable de pouvoir rencontrer
et partager avec les autres peuples
c'est dieu qui nous étions enfermés dans
notre propre pays avec du barbelé
partout publiés on était constamment
sous surveillance après la chute du
régime comme plus d'un million
d'albanais un quart de la population
yak et son fils ont travaillé à
l'étranger en grèce et en italie
ils sont rentrés définitivement il y a
deux ans
[Rires]
rené et claude sont ravis de cette
rencontre autour d'un verre de raki qui
leur a mieux fait comprendre la réalité
du pays
et finalement c'est pour ça qu'on voyage
un petit peu aussi ses travaux c'est
même presque uniquement ça vous voyez